oh wow this girl woke up and chose hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen in today's video we'll be taking
a look at Alexandra Cooper from call her
daddy's Harper Bazaar what I eaten a day
interview a quick reminder to hit in my
description for my disclaimer and for a
link to my free Hunger crushing combo
ebook if you're looking for some more
balanced meal and snack ideas popping in
here for a quick moment folks because I
am super excited to be working with
element again because this is a product
that I was using years ago when I was on
my breastfeeding Saga and it really
really helped me recover and I've gotten
back into it recently because you know
summer was just happening I was out in
the sun I was traveling a lot this
summer and I'm really prone to sunstroke
so I found that this made a huge
difference in how I feel a lot of my
colleagues who work in Sports Nutrition
also swear by elements specifically
because it has a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of 1,000 Mig sodium
200 Mig potassium and 60 Mig magnesium
and it has no colors sugars or fillers
I've also found that having my
electrolytes in the morning has had a
really positive impact on my sleep so
even on days that I'm not sweating a lot
or playing tennis I will usually still
have half a packet I love all things
spicy so the mango chili has always been
a favorite of mine but they have nine
different flavors including their new
grapefruit which I love
and it's now available year round in
their sample pack right now element is
offering my viewers a free sample pack
with any order so that's eight single
serving packets for free with any
element order this is a great way to try
all eight flavors or share element with
a salty friend so get yours at drink
element.com
Abby it's only available through my link
so you've got to go to drn KLM nt.com
slaby sharp so Alex's call her dad daddy
podcast has really exploded since its
release in 2018 if you haven't listened
in she's interviewed huge names like
Miley Cyrus Chelsea Handler John Mayer
and that fake German ays Anna Delby and
is now the highest female podcaster on
Spotify second only to Joe Rogan I don't
know maybe we should all give her a
download to try to change that around
but anyways I am looking forward to
hearing what she eats in a day so let's
hop in I take my Coffee iced coffee
usually and will put oat milk recently
switched from almond to Oat and it's
been a pretty fabulous transition I will
say so myself
o controversial very controversial like
Alex woke up and chose violence with the
oat milk latte at least that's what it
would seem like in Wellness talk but
yeah there is so much hate about oat
milk online these days due to its
so-called toxic ingredients and alleged
ability to spike your blood sugars and
there's even more fear around oat milk
lataste for spiking cortisol as well and
allegedly making you anxious so is this
habit going to cause a mental health
disorder well let's talk about it so
first of all let's talk about these
toxic ingredients using the popular
Oatley brand as an
[Music]
example oat
milk so Wellness creators like to call
out a lot of oat milk brands for
containing di potassium phosphate which
is an additive that helps prevent the
plant-based milks from splitting but not
surprisingly it is totally safe for the
general public and provides about 20% of
your daily phosphorus need there's also
often canola AKA rape seed oil or other
seed oil added into oat milk which as we
have established here on aby's kitchen
ad nauseum it is not only fine in
moderation but it actually has a pretty
favorable Omega 6 to omega3 ratio and
the fact that it makes up less than 2%
of the formula is pretty good evidence
that we should let that one go as for
blood sugars seeing as that oat milk is
derived from a grain and not an animal
or a nut oat milk does contain sugar
it's specifically rich in a sugar called
meltose giving it a glycemic index of 59
Which is higher than most milks except
for coconut at 96 and rice at 86 so yes
if consumed on its own and particularly
with coffee it may increase blood sugars
and eventually result in a little crash
but does this equate to like raging
anxiety probably not and I'm going to
tell you why yes it's true that some
research has found that coffee can
increase cortisol levels which is our
stress hormone but other research has
found no increase in cortisol levels at
all more importantly though if you
regularly consume coffee any impact of
caffeine on cortisol levels seems to
diminish now caffeine can however
transiently increase blood sugar levels
in folks with diabetes but we don't have
to see that same concern in healthy
adults and ironically it actually helps
to reduce the risk of type 2 diabetes
IES longterm so coffee consumption isn't
necessarily bad for long-term blood
glucose management and it doesn't
necessarily increase your anxiety if
you're a regular consumer and not hypers
sensitive and if you are sensitive to
the sugar or the coffee or both all of
this could be easily mitigated by having
a protein Rich breakfast before with it
or even shortly after you know I believe
that people's coffee rituals are sacred
obviously too much coffee is not a good
thing but there are so many benefits to
Coffee it can almost feel like taking a
daily do a medicine for people's mental
and physical functioning so rather than
shame and fearmonger how people like to
take their coffee or whether or not they
drink coffee at all I think it would be
way more helpful for wellness
influencers to be like hey if you notice
a jolt of anxiety after you have your
oat milk latte you might feel better
with some food on board like it's coffee
folks why we got to make everything so
damn complicated I like it but I'm not
dependent on it if that makes sense so
I'm never going out of my way to get it
but when it's brought to me I welcome it
and I cherish the moment and I drink the
whole thing fun fact but research
suggest that coffee addiction may
actually be genetically determined so
there's a DNA variation on the gene
pdss2 that seems to slow caffeine
metabolism and curtail consumption now I
haven't seen Alex's 23 and me results
but it's possible that she's a slow
metabolizer or just has incredible
inherent energy levels that I deeply
deeply Envy as a mom every single
morning unless I'm out of them I have an
every everything bagel toasted with
cream cheese I like to do one bagel with
regular cream cheese one side with chive
okay I'm just going to say it but I
really really really want 2024 to be the
year that Bagels become cool again my
team and I have like full conference
calls about Bagels because our data
analysis shows that they are such a fear
food for so many people I'm going to
blame it on the 2000s for teaching us
that a bagel is equivalent to like six
slices of bread or whatever which by by
the way I debunked right here but I
appreciate that Alex is just like having
her daily bagle without giving a about
the carbs and it sounds like this is a
sacred breakfast ritual for her so if it
works it works but we do know that
there's a lot of importantance soci Tidy
benefits to getting more protein in that
morning meal so to keep it fast and
simple and bump up the satiety Factor
she could add in some like hardboiled or
microwave scrambled eggs or serve it
with some Greek yogurt or a protein
shake on the side I'm a very hangry
individual the success of my
relationship I will say is predicated on
whether I've eaten that day or not my
boyfriend will say you are a different
person when you haven't had food okay
yes this is my whole personality as well
and my husband can attest that since day
one 17 long years ago until today that
that has not changed I am like a child
if I haven't been wellfed you will
[Music]
know
my day usually I go to my office and I'm
sitting in an edit room so there's a lot
of time to snack okay sometimes we'll go
down to the kitchen and maybe get some
fruit Welch snack maybe some chips love
some sour cream and onion Pringles those
Welch's fruit snacks are so so delicious
and yes they are technically made with
real fruit and fruit is technically kind
of the first ingredient but for parents
who are buying these thinking that
they're contributing into a serving of
fruit or replacing a serving of fruit
it's worth pointing out that they're
arguably not that different than gummy
bears and I'll show you why so the first
ingredient while derived from fruit
puree is sugar it's basically a
combination of concentrated fruit puree
that's being completely stripped of its
fiber plus some corn syrup and some
sugar now when any fruit is in
concentrated juice or puree form it's
classified as added or free sugars
because it's no longer baled in the
beneficial fiber that helps to slow down
its absorption and reduce the blood
sugar response now I don't share this to
fearmonger again I think these are
delicious but as a parent I would sooner
classify these as candy than a fruit
snack as the name would suggest you know
I thought about lying because I've
watched some of these videos and I saw
the bone broth I saw the tea and for me
it's going to be a sandwich it's what
makes me feel happy and good thank you
Alex for not lying because no one needs
to see bone broth and tea for lunch ever
ever again like 50 calories is not a
lunch but a Sammy that makes you feel
happy and good I mean I'm here for that
Joe and the juice I will get a tunacado
that crunch that Joe and the juice has
perfected it's unmatched and so I almost
get Joe and the juice a sandwich and
then a smoothie it's like this
strawberry banana almond milk smoothie
it's really good remember the time I
followed the instructions that I read
online on how to make this tunacado
sandwich from Joe and the juice and the
filling ended up literally looking like
cat food I really don't know what kind
of Vlog I was following the recipe from
but do not I repeat do not puree the
tuna it was tragic really but yeah this
combo sounds incredible Viber carbs in
the fruit and bread protein in the tuna
and healthy fats in the avocado and
pesto you know I only beef with Joe and
the juice is that it takes so long to
get you dang drinks and I know it's
because they make every little juice and
wellness shot and snack from scratch to
order but you know when you get behind a
gagle of girls waiting on their asai
bowls and green juices you're waiting
like at least 30 minutes for a latte but
yeah that's my little first problem
right for the day but yeah I just feel
like every single time I go even though
it's so delicious I kind of regret it
but then sometimes I want to heft it up
a little bit and I'll get all about that
bread I basically make some my own
version of an Italian it is ham cheese
lettuce tomato onions Peppers Mayo
mustard salt vinegar pepper and then
I'll eat some Cheetos and shove them in
there or whatever chip I get I love a
chip in a sandwich if you don't like
that I don't trust you I feel pretty
confident that there's at least a few
handfuls of celebrities who have been
interviewed by food Diaries who would
say that they do not love chips on their
sandwich and no offense but I wouldn't
trust them either again I could sit here
and lie and say my go-to for dinner is
salmon and that would be true because I
did cook that recently and that was one
of the first things I've ever tried to
cook it didn't turn out great so I'm
always ordering out okay my favorite
meal if I it's my dying meal it's always
going to be chicken parmesan always
through and through to the core I'm
going down with chicken bar listen I'm a
dietician and I also went to culinary
school so of course I think that having
some basic cooking skills are really
really important and the research also o
supports that cooking at home is
associated with improved diet quality
increased fruit and veg consumption and
increased recognition of healthier foods
but I think social media like especially
Wellness content tends to make it seem
like if you're not cooking three meals a
day from scratch and like batch prepping
gluten-free keto muffins or cookings
midday at 2 p.m. that you're just like
not doing it right honestly most working
people just realistically do not have
time for anything close to this amount
of scratch cook cing and sometimes even
I see this content and I feel like I'm
doing a job it's hard not to feel
self-conscious but as a dietician I
truly believe that even assembling some
super simple little meals can be a
really really great start if Alex loves
chicken Pern but is like terrified of
over or undercooking the chicken she
could easily do like a cheater quick
version by grabbing a rotisserie chicken
taking the breast off the bones topping
it with some Jarred pasta sauce and a
handful of cheese and then throwing
under the broiler to melt serve that
with some boiled pasta a couple handfuls
of spinach in there and some Jarred
sauce and there you go we got a
home-cooked meal that's probably not
quite as good as the LA restaurants
version but is also a lot more nutrient
dense if I have to eat a green I'm going
to go broccoli or asparagus no sometimes
asparagus is too chewy and we don't like
the after effects of what asparagus does
she's talking about asparagus pee and if
you're like what the is that either
never had asparagus or you're part of
the 8% who don't experience it but in
short asparagus is rich in asparagusic
acid creative name I know but
asparagusic acid is a sulfur containing
compound that when metabolized in the
body releases the sulfurous stinky
byproduct so your pee can smell as soon
as 15 minutes after eating asparagus and
can last up to 14 hours interestingly
not everyone experiences asparagus pee
but we're unsure if it's because some
people lack the enzyme that creates that
smelly byproduct or that some people
have a genetic modification on the old
factory receptor in the nose that can
cause them to just not smell it
production hypothesis or the perception
hypothesis we're not really sure what's
right but I do find it kind of hilarious
that a lot of research dollars have been
spent trying to get to the bottom of it
I mean no offense to the authors but I
just can't imagine dragging myself
through like a doctor degree to study
asparagus P but hey makes for a great
little facto that you can all bust out
at your next dinner party when you're
passing along the asparagus anyways
let's go on okay so McConnell's ice
cream is my GH to late night dessert The
Salted Caramel brownie the ooey gooey
double chocolate chip who wants one
flavor of ice cream not me okay so I
have a theory and it's not even like an
unpopular opinion Theory because I feel
like this is a very popular Theory but
argue with me in the comments if you
disagree people who only ever choose the
same single flavor ice cream like
chocolate or vanilla are narcissists yep
I said it especially vanilla like what
the how could you be so seemingly sure
of yourself to not even wonder if
there's something better out there I
need a minimum of two flavors in that
cone and it takes me at least six
samples to decide and I inevitably still
feel uncertain about the decision okay
so I'm kind of joking about the
narcissism or am I if I'm coming home
from a night out this sounds disgusting
okay recently I've been on a kick of
Traitor Joe's egg rolls with ranch
dressing now this is a snack I mean for
a girl who doesn't cook this feels
relatively ambitious for late night
drunk eats and you can't go wrong with
anything tjs and these look pretty damn
good so pork is the first ingredient
with 8 g of protein in two spring rolls
plus a little bit of fiber and it's
obviously a lot lower in fat to bake or
air fry them than to order them in so
yeah I'm totally down for this snack my
death row meal I'm going to go with a
margarita pizza chicken fingers and
fries for my appetizer
with a couple shots of tequila my main
course it would be chicken parm I would
want the pasta to have vodka sauce on it
please don't judge me cuz I want a
little surf and turf and I know that
sounds disgusting but I would have a
lobster tail on the side and I would
have a glass of wine and um the bread
that's like the puffy bread that has
garlic all over it and like the um
melted butter on it a huge bowl of ice
cream but I would want a warmed
chocolate chip cookie shoved into the
side of it yep Alex call me we can 100%
be friends because if you're going down
like this I want in yourself that's a
little
[Music]
sexual anyways on that not folks that is
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave you a comment below
about who or what you'd like to see do
next hit up that description for my free
hung crushing com ebook and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
n